okay so am I just pouring it straight in
here yes okay
how much
very thin I can't
yeah
I'm really nervous
a few minutes
tonight
[Laughter]
maybe the children might want to do
pancakes
they're like Mommy we've seen either but
there's no way okay
please don't show everyone this is my
one
I might have to have a flipping as you
did earlier
here's what I made done
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah okay I'm gonna try and go that's
what I think it's gonna get started yes
all the ones that are made earlier
I'm sorry I haven't done any justice
yeah yeah I just tried to keep the
pancake
there's one what a beautiful pancake
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
the gene you've got to do huh did you
make these hats they're wonderful very
clever lady